please welcome somebody that i just can
easily go out on the limb and say we all
love this person so much fred savage
we thought we were gonna get to work
with you last year we were so bad it
worked out though i know and actually
it's better because it's in person and
there's something to talk about i
remember when i was gonna come like you
should come to drew and i was like i
can't come to do with like old stories
about college like i have to have a real
something to talk about and i do well
we've been waiting for two years
it's very exciting for you to come on
the show and i'm with you too like i'm
not a big go on talk shows to just talk
you want something to talk about yeah i
mean kind of although we can find things
i feel like we're chatty people we can
find some common ground you know but
also uh okay so you and i have another
thing in common we're both some of the
youngest people to host snl this is true
this is true which
this is a real source of pride uh yes
but you i think you were the
what was that
my god
thirteen sir i was 13 years old i was
how old were you you were younger i was
seven
i mean
oh my god
and we have macaulay culkin in between
us and that's always been the first
second and third youngest people still
there's no one who's touched these
records in all these years uh that's
amazing that's amazing oh that's my
sister my sister in real life played on
on the show with me did she have fun she
had the best time my sister was in it my
mom was in it no way that julia lee
dreifus was in the camp
no way we and i was with eddie murphy uh
julie louise dreyfus um
joe piscopo and julie louise dreyfuss
ended up marrying brad hall who's next
to her and they're still happily married
tim kazurinsky mary gross robin duke
and gary kroger
i mean i remember it do you remember do
you remember it like vividly yes what do
you remember yeah very clearly very
clearly i remember and steven spielberg
came because he was very paternal with
me were you nervous like did you know
what you were doing do you know like you
were on saturday live
i wasn't nervous yeah me either i didn't
really know i didn't really appreciate
it i mean i did appreciate it but like
my dad was really excited i grew up
watching it but i wasn't yeah i wasn't
nervous about it do you think that you
and i grew up in a way where we lacked
that nervous gene because we started
working so young i think so
i also really resonate with your story
in that
you
were an actor
you went behind the scenes and you
became this
huge
director
i mean your your credit you're insane
your imdb pages it's like a scroll
um okay will you play a game with me
yeah okay
um
because your
credits are so long okay and you've
worked on so many illustrious shows okay
i wanted to take a look back with you
and play a little game that's one of my
favorites here it's called behind the
scenes let's
[Applause]
go okay
so
i mean literally there's like that's so
raven drake and josh like you had a
whole disney era in 1999 that's where i
started doing like kid stuff you also
did hannah montana i want i want i want
i want something i did hannah montana
what have you got
bring me fly on the wall hannah montana
okay so hannah montana was actually like
a big turning point for me as a director
and so i did this thing i don't know if
you've ever done this as an actress or
as a director
where
you start to hold things at arm's length
a little bit and say well i'm doing it
but that's not really who i am or what i
want to be doing and i got like snobby
you know to be honest if i'm laying it
out there and when i did hannah montana
i'm like you know what
i'm not doing
my best work i need to like really
commit to the thing so i had all this
when i was preparing for hannah montana
i'm like this is the best episode of
hannah montana like i'm gonna pour
everything into it and it was about a
girl who was bullying hannah and she
realized hannah's like what's going on
she realized that she herself was very
fragile and that's why she was bullying
hannah and i'm like this scene is about
identity and about like crisis and about
friendship and healing wounds i'm like
this is gonna be the best performance
these actresses have ever given their
lives and i stand by it it was okay what
was like you commit to it miley cyrus
like because she's a deep bird that i
don't think that she's looking to stay
in a box she was the best and was a
delight i mean she was really young but
it was she was awesome she was awesome
okay yeah modern family the best the
best give me a fly on the wall moment
like
final moment like it was incredibly
daunting but at the same time um it was
really inspiring and once i did my first
episode and got like invited back it was
like getting to sit at like the cool
kids table because the first time
they're like hey come sit with us like
oh no no you have the wrong guy like no
come on and when you got invited back i
was like oh i'm in and it was it was
great it was really great um i love that
yeah i love that
okay blackish blackish
was a show
um that i have loved since the moment it
came on and there was a minute when it
first aired like oh would you want to
come direct some i'm like i
um
love the show but i feel like those
aren't my stories to tell and then like
when i came to do one i realized i was
so in my own head i was like no these
are story these are stories about the
the point of that show is that these are
stories about
family and growing up and um struggles
at home and struggles at work and
these are universal stories and that
really
doing those you know handful of episodes
over blackish i think gave me the
confidence to come do this new uh
iteration of the wonder years um for
that same idea of there are there's
there's um there's universality in the
specificity of these stories and well
that was going to be my next question
that's a perfect parlay
into
the wonder years lee daniels calls you
or he's a part of the producing team lee
daniels had the rights and he was like
do you want to be a part of this and i
did the same thing this sounds like a
great idea but this is like lee's story
to tell like i think he's the perfect
guy to tell this story because what it
was always from the beginning to tell a
story about an african-american family
um and how it was the one of yours for
this family as well and so i was like
this is a great idea i think you're the
right guy to do it i can't wait to watch
it and this was years ago and then he
came back
um
celadean patterson is a guy who wrote
and created this new iteration of the
wonder years and i had worked with him
before he's just like one of the best
people he's a great writer great
comedian but just one of the best people
best men i've met you know just a great
person
and um he's like i'm gonna be writing it
and i'm not gonna do it without you he's
like i love this this is
yeah
i love that he's like
he wrote about he wrote about his
experience he grew up in tuskegee
alabama and this show takes place in
montgomery and he goes i'm writing about
my family and my experiences and i'm
telling you like this this is our story
to tell together
and like that invitation in so being so
partnered with him and saudi and lee
it's just an incredible than an
incredible team
[Music]
you